if we just dial it back a few years to
kind of what we inherited here
the former president invested billions
of dollars in a border wall that was
never going to work or be effective
instead of working towards comprehensive
immigration reform as part of the
president's proposal he put forward on
his first day in office he proposed
investing in smarter security at the
border something he'd be happy to work
uh with governors on and and certainly
we're we're open to having that
conversation whenever they're ready to
do that go ahead
and think more broadly on the ukrainian
aid sure since the russian invasion
started the us has provided more than 5
billion
total when you factor in military
economic humanitarian aid is there a
figure
that
is a cap for what the us is willing and
able to provide ukraine
well i would say that the range of
military assistance that we've provided
to date was meant to be front loaded
because of our expectation or
anticipation led by our department of
defense and military leaders about the
nature of the fight and how it has
evolved right that because they're on a
terrain now that where they're in need
of long-range military capacity we've
tried to expedite the assistance over
the past couple of weeks that they're
receiving so it might not be over the
next couple of weeks the same size of
assistance week by week but in terms of
what the next package will look like and
what will be passed i mean those are
discussions and recommendations that the
president will get from his military
leaders we'll have those discussions
with congress i'm i'm not in a position
to put a cap on it at this point in time
okay got it and then just switching over
to covid um the administration is
planning to take new actions to expand
pax lobed yeah is there anything you can
share about
how you plan to do that and who might be
eligible since right now it's only for
people who are at higher risk sure well
part of it is even people who are
eligible are not taking advantage of the
fact that they're eligible so part of
our effort is to share more information
publicly about who can get access who
can call their doctor
and get access to it i will tell you dr
zha is going to make his debut in the
briefing room tomorrow um so he will lay
out for you and others more specifically
all the steps we're taking to increase
knowledge of paxlovid who can benefit
from it i don't think we're intending to
and i'll let him speak to this say
there's going to be an expansion of
who's eligible as much as we're and i'll
obviously leave that to the health
experts to determine but more we need to
focus on making sure that everybody who
is eligible knows they're eligible and
they can gain access to it because it is
is very effective in treating covet
thank you good job yeah just a couple on
twitter i want to go back try again
are you concerned about
the kind of purveyors of election
misinformation disinformation
um help falsehoods sort of
having more of an opportunity to speak
there on twitter is there you know any
message that you would convey to elon
musk as the new
owner
well i would just
maybe just add to it that you know
public publicly traded companies have
different levels
of um there's different levels of
security you know scrutiny that are
possible of publicly traded companies
so are you concerned about
you know a billionaire taking control of
a company that where there's already a
lot of concentration of power
i would say that our our concerns are
not new uh we've long talked about and
the president has long talked about his
concerns about the power of social media
platforms including twitter and others
to
spread misinformation disinformation
the need for these platforms to be held
accountable
well i know you tried again i appreciate
that i still don't have a specific
comment on this specific transaction um
and at this point we don't have any
sense of what the policies will look
like okay um and then uh
last week delete singh made some very
strong comments and uh also treasury
secretary yellen makes comments about
the positive impact on inflation of
lowering tariffs on certain
chinese goods bicycles underwear apparel
um it's quite obvious yeah
is there something cooking can you tell
us something and do you notice the white
house embracing that is that something
we could see happen soon
so from the beginning of the
administration we talked about how some
of the tariffs
implemented by the previous
administration were not strategic and
instead raised cost on americans and our
effort which has been ongoing of course
has been to ensure current section 301
tariffs align appropriately with our
economic and trade priorities and you
mentioned you know different goods that
are sold but of course on wages and job
opportunities uh
critical supply chains where we see
critical impacts on critical supply
change
are the our ability to sustain our
technological edge uh this is an ongoing
process and we're certainly looking at
where we see costs being raised and a
time where we're seeing uh heightened
inflation certainly that's on our minds
it's also about addressing the core
issues we have with how china has
approached
you know their engagement around
economic issues as well so it's both
so
can we look for some tariff rejections
in some
relatively short period of time we're
continuing to review it um i don't have
anything at this moment to preview for
you but our focus is on those same
categories and areas where we can impact
where we think they're impacting wages
and job opportunities our technological
edge that's the prism through which our
economic team uh ambassador thai is of
course leading this effort is reviewing
uh these these sanctions
um so the sanctions that have been
imposed and i realized they're quite
sleeping and large but on especially on
oligarchs and other people close to
putin have thus far excluded his
girlfriend
his name i can't quite my name is kaioba
um do you
have any comment on why you would
refrain from sanctioning someone
arguably close to putin
well i would remind you we're continuing
to review sanctions no one is safe
from our sanctions we've already of
course sanctioned president putin but
also his daughter his closest cronies
and will continue to
review more so i wouldn't i don't have
an analysis at this point because we're
still reviewing there's more we will
likely do
go ahead jen on just the broader
strategy of helping ukraine there's
obviously hurting russia economically
hurting russia militarily given that the
u.s has ruled out so many economic
sanctions already against russia and the
heavy fighting that we're seeing now
should we expect that the help that the
us offers you going forward would be
more uh heavily like militarily focused
as opposed to economic or is that the
wrong way of looking at it is sort of
all of these no it's i i understand your
question i think these are all
discussions that we're having through
the interagency and there'll be a
recommendation made to the president i
mean there's no question they need
additional military assistance as part
of secretary austin's follow-up to his
trip to ukraine he was
in germany today uh meeting to discuss
kind of the next steps and what their
needs are as this as the as the battle
and the war continues to evolve but they
are also going to have significant
humanitarian and economic uh needs as
well so i would expect that all of them
will continue to be touched on but these
are the discussions that are happening
in the interagency process now and is
there any new
updated u.s assessment on any discontent
or disagreement within putin's top
advisors or inner circle about the
direction of the war
i i don't have any assessment i can read
up from here any new assessment and just
one more on a different topic just on
inflation given that it continues to be
such a big concern for so many people
the president obviously doesn't have the
luxury of wandering outside the white
house he can't you know go fill up his
car or go to the grocery store can you
give us a sense of how he sort of is
updated every day how he gets a sense of
how much does milk cost more today than
a week ago just how does he sort of keep
up to date on how much more expensive
things are for the average american i
can assure you that the president sees
himself as the kid from scranton more
than many people who work in his
administration and he is often the
person who reminds people
and members of his policy team in
meetings
what the impacts of rising food costs or
gasoline costs or other issues are
he does request and receive regular
updates from his economic team and often
when he returns from uh weekends at home
in delaware he comes back with
conversations he had with people as he
came out of church or you know as he uh
people he's known for a long time in his
community and they often tell him about
how these uh how the rising costs impact
his life so i would say that he stays
abreast of these changes and of these
increases in costs and the impacts
through economic data and briefings but
also through his own conversations
whenever he can have them yeah
go ahead i have a question here about uh
following the recent palestinian terror
attacks from the temple mount and
previous week of attacks that have
killed many israelis and wounded more
is the body administration reconsidering
its support of the palestinian
authorities two-state solution dividing
israel or stopping the welfare payments
sent to the palestinian authority who
use the money for their pay to slay
reward system and have a follow-up
question okay well i would just note
that i spoke to this uh last week uh on
wednesday where i noted that the united
states is deeply concerned by the recent
violence in jerusalem on the temple
mount across the west bank and we also
strongly condemn the recent rocket
attack on israel you may or may not have
seen also that the president conducted a
call with prime minister bennett on
sunday morning he accepted an invitation
by prime minister bennett to visit
israel in the coming months no specific
date yet he took note of the ongoing
efforts between israeli and palestinian
officials to lower tensions and ensure a
peaceful conclusion to the holy season
of ramadan and he also uh affirmed his
our unwavering support for israel and
its defense needs and welcomed the
historic 1 billion allocation to
replenish israel's iron dome system
yes in view of continued palestinian
violence against innocent civilians is
the body administration willing to stop
payments to the anti-semitic u.n agency
umrah and support restoring the jewish
cemetery in vilnius lithuania to its
former glory again i i think i i don't
have any changes to announce to our
policy i spoke to our condemnation of
the violence just now as last and last
week as well and noted also our call to
the prime minister go ahead i wanted
clarification on the aid that the us has
already allocated to ukraine sure the
president said last week that he had
almost exhausted his draw down ability
so how much after that announcement of
the 800 million on thursday does the u.s
have left to provide ukraine i'm sure i
can get you this specific exact number
it was almost about 3.5 billion total uh
of drawdown authority i believe i will
double check that number for you so what
he was referring to is because of how
quickly we've been moving the military
assistance uh to the ukrainians on the
ground we anticipated being almost at a
near end of
that draw down authority so that's why
he's going to afford a new package this
week
debt cancellation yesterday senator
elizabeth warren said that the white
house has essentially already cancelled
some student debt by waiving interest on
that student debt and it could use that
same exact authority to cancel student
debt permanently does the white house
agree with that view this is about the
authority not whether you will but that
you can derive the authority in the same
exact way i don't have anything to
preview for you in terms of any
authority and how or how it would work
what i would tell you is that not a
single person in this country has paid a
dime on student federal student loans
since the president took office and what
we have said is that he would make a
decision about any cancellation of
student debt uh before the conclusion of
that pause on student loans but i don't
have anything to preview for you at this
point in time
she said that it was an issue of racial
equity does the white house view this as
a racial equity issue well again i think
uh the president views uh student loan
relief debt relief as something that
impacts yes it is a racial equity issue
but it is also an issue that impacts
many individuals young people middle
aged people of all races it is something
that he has uh he has uh played a has
been a vital uh priority to the
president which again is why not not a
single person has played paid a penny a
dime a dime or a penny um in student uh
loans since he took office go go go
ahead jj i don't want to forget go ahead
oh thanks um two questions of the
supplemental fudging yeah one on cedric
richmond yeah um on the supplemental has
the administration decided to definitely
combine the covid funding with the aid
for ukraine we don't have the mechanism
yet these are conversations that we'll
have with congress obviously prior to
the recess there was the proposal that
did combine uh but but not don't have a
don't have a sense yet
and then is the white house considering
extending the title 42 immigration
restrictions as part of a deal with with
congress are you considering it again
this would be congress having the
discussion we're continuing to prepare
for a may 23rd implementation um
there'll be a range of conversations
about this over the coming days
is reporting that richmond is leaving is
he and just last week he said publicly
that he wouldn't leave unless the
president asked him to
so something changed there
yes okay well let me first say um that
um cedric richmond has been continues to
be
a vital essential advisor to the
president was on the campaign continues
to be in the white house i have been in
many meetings with cedric richmond where
the president goes to him and looks to
him for his political sense his
assessment of congress he trusts him
implicitly
i have nothing to announce at this point
but i can assure you when we have
something to announce and we'll involve
a new important role too
for cedric richmond and something the
president is uh excited about and has
asked him to do go ahead
we saw the radar from the call of the
french president did the president see
any larger meaning in the french
elections in terms of the support of the
allied effort against russia
i don't have any assessment of that can
i i'll leave that to others to do
analysis of the president was pleased
with the
with the outcome as you know he spoke
with president macron this morning and
he's looking forward to continuing to
work with him
in standing up against russian
aggression and standing with the
ukrainian people
it's as long as
tweeted an interesting observation that
president macron secured a double-digit
victory at a time when his approval
rating was 36
was there anything he was suggesting
i don't have any more analysis to
provide on that front though appreciate
the question go ahead
on nato uh reports in finland and sweden
say that the country the two countries
are preparing to apply to join nato as
early as next month is the white house
supportive of that effort well those are
decisions for these countries to make
and for the nato alliance to make uh and
so we'll leave it to those entities
um we learned more about friday's
shooter today from from d.c police
who say he had hundreds of rounds of
unspent ammo inside his connecticut
avenue apartment and today the the d.c
mayor announced a new police initiative
to target
violent crime does the president believe
he's done all he can do
to fight violent crime
gun
issues around this country without the
intervention of congress
well he will continue to look uh for
every authority he has to take steps to
address gun violence um violent crimes
across the country the last time we had
data
was in 2020 i believe and at that time
about 77 percent of homicides were done
with a firearm and you saw him talk two
weeks ago now it's all running together
but two weeks ago now i believe about
ghost guns and the steps that he is
going to continue to take to address
ghost guns which we have seen um have a
rising role in uh in in uh in gun um and
gun deaths and gun targeting over the
past uh several um months i would also
note that then when he was doing that
event he highlighted that two la
sheriff's deputies who've been wounded
by a shooter using a ghost gun so that's
just even an example of how even they're
using these ghost guns are being used to
target police as well which is also a
problem so i would say of course there
are significant steps that congress can
take that would make these laws
permanent that is the president's first
preference
whether it's background checks banning
assault weapons these are laws that he's
led the effort to pass throughout his
career many decades but he will continue
to look for any steps he can take using
his own authorities as he has done
several times since uh taking office i
think he's done more than any other
president using executive authority good
thanks jen two questions for you um
president biden made his first
endorsement of the midterm election
cycle on saturday
endorsing congressman curt schroeder why
didn't you decide to weigh in on this
race uh first and what would he say to
some progressives who are frustrated
that he endorsed trader over
i certainly understand your question i
don't make the rules but the rules are i
can't speak a lot about politics from
here so i would point to the dnc and i
would point you to congressman
schroeder's office
for you there's been a fair bit of
speculation about vladimir putin's
health based on recent videos of him has
the white house made an assessment on
this matter and uh have concerns been
raised internally at all about this
topic i don't have any assessment for to
offer from here or any particular
comment on the mental health of
president putin good yeah
got to title 42 quickly i'm
i hear you talking about discussions
going forward the debate that's
happening all of that
are you saying that title 42 i know
you're prepared uh to lift the current
policy may 23rd are you saying that will
happen unless congress acts or are you
saying the white house might do
something else congress would have to
take action in order for the date not to
be may 23rd
on hunter biden the new york post is
reporting
looking at white house visitor logs
there were 19 visits to the white house
while the president was vice president
by hunter biden's business partner
including one with the vice president do
you help us understand why that business
partner had access and what those
meetings were about
i i don't have any information on that
i'm happy to check and see if we've any
more comment former senator david perdue
last night hoping to be a senator again
opened his debate by saying that the
election 2020 election was rigged and
stolen um we know that uh every court
most court courts have ruled that it was
fair
there's no evidence of fraud but i
wonder what you make of those comments
and has the white house done enough uh
to push back and to make it clear that
the election was not stolen i think that
speaks to the former president's hold
over factions of the republican party
not facts go ahead thank you so much jen
two questions uh on brazil first uh last
friday president biden said the united
states and which countries should be
paying brazil to protect the amazon and
he said he's trying to get this done so
what exactly is he trying to do is he
trying to work with other rich countries
negotiating with brazil
is he ready to provide financial support
to brazil and how much would that be
so uh the science is in in the
president's view and the reason he made
these comments is that the science has
only become more clear that the world
needs to both strengthen and accelerate
emissions reductions and part of that
goal is concern includes conserving
global forest ecosystems that remove
carbon from the atmosphere and store
more carbon than they emit in a year
serving as carbon sinks so president
biden recognized the necessity of
mobilizing funding from the whole got
from world governments in the private
sector and the plan to conserve global
forest the critical carbon sinks
launched at cop26 aims to mobilize
finance from the public and private
sector with a strong focus on levering
private sector finance through market
mechanisms so that's what he was
speaking to and certainly an effort he
continues to support and uh there is a
delegation today from the state
department in brazil i wonder um if this
trip has anything to do with the war in
ukraine and perhaps the united states
seeking or interested in working with
brazil food and energy
security i would really point to the
state department we are working with a
range of countries obviously and
addressing where we can see any food
shortages um around the world um and
obviously ukraine is front and center on
the minds of most global leaders and
just a quick one why president body has
declined to talk with president
bolsonaro we know that the brazilian
government's trying has been trying to
try more than once so i see declining i
don't have any update the president
obviously has a busy schedule he has
spoken with a range of global leaders
but not every single one and you just
know the state department is in brazil
for a visit so i would note we have an
ongoing dialogue at a high level go
ahead
go ahead
oh okay either one okay
you're kind of matching today
yeah there you go in your suits
in blue
so more people are starting to talk
about recession goldman sachs and bank
of america alluded to it um
because of inflation uh the steps that
have been taken so far haven't seemed to
work to get inflation to come back down
what additional steps are you guys
looking at to curb inflation as well as
the feeling that the economy's headed
the wrong direction
well i would say first um there are a
number of strong economic indicators
that we would point to we created more
jobs last year than any year in american
history the unemployment rate is at 3.6
percent we know that costs are too high
inflation which the federal reserve has
purview over still projects that it will
moderate by the end of the year there
are a number of steps they have and they
have indicated they have in the plans to
recalibrate we support that effort they
have a lot of power here in terms of
taking steps to address inflation we are
not uh the president is not waiting uh
for
that to happen and he's taking steps to
address where we see costs increasing in
different areas that impact the american
people's pocketbooks whether it's gas
prices obviously he made an announcement
to tap the strategic petroleum reserve
led the global release led an effort to
release from the
globally to bring down gas prices we've
also taken steps to
fix issues with our supply chain to make
sure goods are moving as quickly as
possible and there's a lot of interest
continues to be in congress to take
steps to lower costs on prescription
drugs health care elder care child care
those are all steps that are based on
the president's proposals the president
has pushed those spending proposals the
san francisco federal reserve released a
report would be fully paid for so
they're not actually spending proposals
their proposals to lower costs that are
fully paid for
the san francisco federal reserve
released a report saying that government
spending accounted for three percent of
the inflation that we're seeing now so
is spending more really the way to go
well again i think if you look back at
where we were a year and a half ago
we're at the point where there was a
significant economic downturn where
people were really suffering struggling
to put food on the table uh certain
people were out of work
and what we've done what we did at that
time is take steps to help stem that
economic downturn and that was a
decision made that the president
continues to believe was in the interest
of the american people
on china the looking at more lockdowns
now beijing may be involved in that
is there anything that the
administration is looking at doing to
help the supply chains uh if this clogs
up again
yeah so we're we're following this very
closely um and as you know there are um
a couple of different issues at play
here there's obviously
shenzhen which has kind of reopened and
they had moved around where their goods
were being produced and moved around
which ports they were going through
shanghai obviously and there are a
couple of industries that were being
impacted
we haven't seen at this point a decrease
in ships coming to our ports in
california from asia we obviously are
continuing to monitor that and beijing
is uh has increased their testing which
could be a precursor to
a lockdown but we don't we don't know at
this point so what we're doing right now
is we're closely monitoring the state
department is our economic team is um
and but we haven't seen a slowdown in
ships coming to our ports in california
if if there's an increase as as
lockdowns decrease in some parts of
china we'll also be prepared for that
because we've been able to um take steps
to reduce the number of cargo ships
there
one just one question uh
there's been um there's been a lot of
explosions and strange fires at quite
significant places in russia over the
last couple of weeks just most recently
in the city of brian's as oil
containers blew up
uh there's a lot of speculation over
what's causing it and obviously one of
the theories would be that the ukraine
is somehow doing it
what is the us position on ukraine
attacking inside russian territories
it's something that the u.s has
encouraged would encourage them to do
and try and help them
in terms of the weapons or is it
something maybe where you advise ukraine
is not to go there oh i don't we don't
have any confirmation of that ukraine is
defending their own country so i'm just
not going to speak to a hypothetical you
know i'm asking for confirmation on
things that have happened it's just
there's obviously a lot of speculation
and it's kind of an obvious point right
like they're fighting the russians too
for nail inside their own country quite
often near the borders
and the russians are inside their
country so is there a u.s position
on
um on whether ukraine should have the
right
or maybe be encouraged to take their
fight beyond their border again that is
a hypothetical so i'm not going to speak
to it ukraine's country is being invaded
russia is invading their country that's
what we're supporting them for and
there's been no confirmation of what
you're detailing so i'm just not going
to speak to that
if i may uh just
we know that congressional hispanic
caucus members are here meeting with the
president i wonder if immigration and
also title 42 has been discussed and i
don't know how much it can reveal about
that meeting that is taking place this
afternoon so um i don't have a readout
of the meeting at this point in time i
would note that uh this is part of the
series of meetings as i noted earlier
that the president is doing with a range
of the caucuses in congress he did the
congressional black caucus he did kpac
and he did these last year as well so we
certainly expect immigration to be a
topic of discussion but i would note
that the chc also has a stated position
on title 42
as a caucus which is that they oppose
any change to the decisions that that
has been made so anything could be
discussed but i wouldn't anticipate that
being a topic a major topic
if i may on um transition
but uh if i'm on transnistria there's
been some kind of attack on the ministry
of state security um
we know that moscow has been talking
about this area possibly entering the
conflict it seemed it happened on a
holiday when there wouldn't have been
people in the building
does this bear the hallmarks of a false
flag operation of the story you've been
warning us about yeah
i've seen the reports i i don't
obviously we have of course but i don't
have any confirmation of the specifics
or the details at this point
yeah i just have two um the first is
with the chc coming yeah some have
wanted biden the administration to do
more on executive actions related to
immigration um
and i guess just philosophically does
the president believe that he's
exhausted most of the things that he
could do through executive power you had
alluded earlier about the legislative
push sure are there things that he feels
like he could still do
through executive actions related i mean
i think his his view is that um taking
steps and working with congress to pass
comprehensive immigration reform that
has smarter security that does put in
place an asylum processing system that
works is the best step that will have a
lasting impact
obviously we're continuing to assess any
executive actions we can take but he'll
i think continue to discuss legislative
actions as well
secondly you had mentioned this at the
top about the toxic exposures um and
that the president wants comprehensive
um
comprehensive legislation um to be
passed uh the house has passed a version
related as the senate has passed a
version
the senate version is sometimes
criticized by advocates of not going far
enough so does the president have a
stance on which piece of legislation he
views as addressing this issue
comprehensively is he getting involved
in that there's other legislation that's
that hasn't been passed in the senate
that also grapples with this issue sure
i mean obviously as you know now the
next step is for
both bodies of congress to work together
and figure out the path forward we did
issue a sap on the pac act um so beyond
that i don't think i have anything more
to update you on that position
thanks jen uh i had a question on title
42 at the risk of this being a dumb
question um
so if the cdc
is able to extend title 42 why is it up
to congress can you tell people
understand why why it's on congress to
extend it now sure congress gave the cdc
authority to determine when the
conditions would be met to lift title 42
which again has never been an
immigration authority or an immigration
policy it's always been a health
authority so when they determined we no
longer had the conditions where we had
to
take action to quickly deport people who
came to the country they made that
health decision based on data and
science and the cdc decision making
congress would need to make any decision
about a change to the authority they
gave the cdc
he doesn't have the authority to just
say things have changed if the health
and data
conditions changed they could certainly
make a different decision i sure but uh
they make decisions based on health and
data not based on politics or uh where
members of congress sit another
protovirus
follow up on that that question uh and
something that was asked earlier
does
is the president willing to sign
something if it comes to his desk as
part of a legislative package
that would change the rules for how uh
title 42 is administered it because
if it is in fact
it is up to congress ultimately that
would get to the president's desk and he
would ultimately have to either sign it
or veto it
there's a lot of steps between now and
then so at this point that's very
premature there are many members who
strongly would like to see title 42
extended there are many who strongly
have the other point of view so we are
not anywhere near that point in time go
ahead
the surgeon general has said that
misinformation about covet amounts to a
public health crisis yeah i'm wondering
regardless of ownership
would the white house be interested in
working with twitter like it has in the
past to continue to combat this kind of
misinformation
or are we in a different part of the
pandemic where that kind of partnership
is no longer necessary well i think we
engage regularly with all social media
platforms about steps that can be taken
that has continued and i'm sure it will
continue uh but there are also reforms
that we think congress could take um and
we would support taking uh including
reforming section 230 enacting
anti-trust reforms requiring more
transparency and the president is
encouraged by the bipartisan uh support
for or engagement in in those efforts
on the us and its allies in the pacific
they've clearly been uh blindsided by
china's security pact with the solomon
islands very strategic
location um kurt campbell was down there
only last week and he announced some
initiatives on you know speeding up the
embassy there yeah um you know sending a
hospital vote that sort of thing the
question is why wouldn't you why
wouldn't the u.s commit to far more
significant security slash military
initiatives in such a strategic place
like that and also i wonder what would
the biden administration work from other
countries australia hasn't exactly been
very well prepared for this chinese
solomon agreement either yeah it's a
great group of questions i have not
talked to kurt campbell about this since
he returned i'm not sure if the
president has i can i can see if there's
anything more we can update you on in
our policies thank you and the president
issued a statement
do the president just issued a statement
on malaria day since the time you
started speaking almost 100 children
have died of malaria he said
two
children a child dies every two minutes
of malaria is the present prepared to
increase funding maybe fight malaria the
same way the u.s has been fighting kovi
it's obviously something the president
cares deeply about as we do as an
administration i don't have anything for
you in terms of predictions of
additional funding um i can see if
there's anything more from usaid
on the tps i know the administration has
just granted tps to communion leaving
the u.s why not extend it to ethiopia
and nigeria other african countries they
are also in crisis yeah i know you've
asked me a similar question before it's
an effort or a process led by the
department of homeland security to make
a determination about conditions on the
ground and an interagency process i
don't i don't have anything to predict
at this point obviously they're
continuing to assess i wanted to ask
about your announcement from last week
on refugees from ukraine yeah um i know
you're supposed to open the portal for
applications today yeah vhs can you talk
about how you're preparing the resources
to be able to accept
what i'm sure is going to be a big
influx of applications as soon as that
portal opens so the department of
homeland security is going to do a
briefing this afternoon for more with
more details
to provide to you and obviously they
will oversee the process and you're
right we certainly anticipate lots of
interest on on both sides
someone in the white house i know when
you were working on
operation afghans welcome yeah someone
in charge of it from this end is there
going to be someone over here that's
working on it sure obviously russia and
ukraine and implementing all of our
programs is a top priority for the
national security team i'll see if there
is one individual who'll be responsible
questions
and the tariffs potentially coming off
can you speak about anything that
president biden has done
to determine the source of the
coronavirus with china
you